Speaker 1: within minutes of yesterday's
announcement that New York Attorney General
Letitia James is suing Trump and his
family for $250 million in seeking to bar
his organization from doing business in New
York over multiple instances of alleged fraud.
Donald Trump took to his failed social media
platform truth social, also known as truth
essential to Trump and viciously attacked Letitia
James, not defending himself on the merits,
but just attacking Letitia James. Let's take
a look at a few of these posts. Donald Trump
starting with, quote, another witch hunt by
a racist attorney general, Letitia James,
who failed in her run for governor, getting almost
zero support from the public and now is doing
poorly against law and order. Attorney General
Candidate, highly respected. Michael Henry. I
never thought this case would be brought until I
saw her really bad poll numbers implying it's all
political. She is a fraud who campaigned on a get
Trump platform. Despite the fact that the city is
one of the crime and murder disasters of the world
under her watch. Trump Continuing Attorney General
Letitia Peekaboo. James I have no clue what
peekaboo is all about. A total crime fighting
disaster in New York is spending all of her time
fighting for very powerful and well represented.
Banks and insurance companies who were fully paid,
made a lot of money and never had a complaint
about me. Instead of fighting murder and violent
crime, which is killing New York State, she is
a failed attorney general whose lack of talent in
the fight against crime is causing record numbers
of people and companies to flee New York. Bubba
I. And then lastly, Trump continuing his attack,
not defending himself on the charges, but just
attacking the messenger. The New York Times,
her peekaboo James case against him could be
difficult to prove. Property valuations are
often subjective, and the financial statements
include a very strong disclaimer. Thank you.
So this is going to be a fight, but it is problem
after problem for Donald Trump. And I'll be
I'll be perfectly frank with you. I don't know
whether Trump plans to run for president in 24.
I don't know whether Trump believes that running
for president will somehow insulate him from the
repercussions of all of these legal problems. The
people doing the prosecution say it will not. But
it remains to be seen. But it is increasingly
looking like it's going to be really difficult
to run for president at the same time that there
are so many legal problems that you're facing.
We'll see what ultimately happens. And
all of these clips that I played for you
are available on our Instagram, which you can
find by searching Instagram for David Pakman show